uh okay so i'd like to talk to you about
um a symbol that means uh a lot to me
means a lot in terms of the work that i
do which is related to nanoscience and
so one of the fundamental symbols so one
of the fundamental quantities related to
a wave is it's its wavelength lambda or
its frequency nu so that's spelt
n u
it comes from the greek and it's the the
the greek symbol nu looks looks like
that that again is another convention
that these symbols have been used alpha
beta gamma nu epsilon
it's historical they've been introduced
by various physicists along the way so
the other symbol that is used is is
actually f and that's in the more recent
textbooks including our first year
physics textbook you'll see fuse more
more than you um
don't quite know the reason for that i
quite like new myself but um f has
certainly used a lot more i think
perhaps the best way
is if i bring out the trusty guitar here
so frequency
when i pluck this
this string
that string vibrates back and forth at a
certain rate per second there are so
many vibrations per second that sets the
air molecules into motion and then they
in turn vibrate back and forth and they
vibrate back and forth on the eardrum so
the key thing with frequency is
that's a relatively low frequency
that's a relatively high frequency and
all you're doing there is changing the
number of times per second that string
moves up and down
you can think of it all in terms of
sound waves but you can also think of it
in terms of light waves so what with
with light
light that we can see in this room or
light coming from distant stars that is
actually another wave but in this case
what it is is a wave um of of
the electromagnetic field okay so what
you have is a
basically a field that's vibrating
back and forth and what's interesting is
in this case that the faster that feel
vibrates back and forth then the diff
you see a difference in color and this
goes all the way not just in terms of
the the visible spectrum that we can see
where you go from red to blue so red is
a relatively low frequency blue is a
much higher frequency but it also goes
all the way down to infrared and
actually down to much lower
frequencies all the way up to two x-rays
which are very very hard very high
frequency
lots of vibrations per second if we
place it i guess in the context of radio
waves where
i guess people are interested i've heard
of kilohertz and megahertz
when we're talking about i guess a key
thing is the is the vibrations on the
atomic scale we're talking about um
at least a million times um
more
million to a billion times greater level
of um frequency so these things are
flipping back and forth very very very
many more times a second than your
conventional radio wave the interesting
thing is that the smaller you make it
the larger the frequency becomes so if i
can grab a ruler um
it's a really useful one
so let's if we let's do a really simple
demo um so we've got something which
here is 25 centimeters long so if we
vibrate that we see that it oscillates
it wobbles back and forth at a few times
every second something like that so
that's its resonant frequency that's the
frequency it likes to to vibrate at and
then so if we make it a little bit
shorter see now so it's 15 centimeters
you'll see that the resonant frequency
has increased we make it a little bit
shorter still now we're down to nine
centimeters you can see that
dies out a little bit quicker but you
can see that the frequency is is much is
greater and if you imagine trying to
make that really really really really
really small so this was only a few um a
fraction of a millimeter you know a few
tenths or a few hundredths of a
millimeter then the frequency actually
goes up to tens or maybe hundreds of
kilohertz thousands of hertz and then if
you go those extra few steps those extra
few orders of magnitude resist for
powers of 10 down to the the range of
the individual atoms and molecules then
we're going into the terahertz regime
where you've got a bit sorry a million
million hertz 10 to the 12 10 to the
power of 12 words
we have this picture of atoms and
molecules be and electrons and small
particles being like billiard balls when
in fact they're not
really at the quantum level in the the
nanos in the nanoworld what we have um
are
basically matter waves so matter stops
behaving like these little billiard
balls that we have this picture of in
our heads and actually spread out and
they have a wave associated with them
and what's remarkable is that is the
fundamental physics of waves the same
type of physics that you apply to the
guitar
to a large extent you can also apply to
the the behavior of matter at the at the
quantum level
up until the early years of the 20th
century the classical picture was that
that atoms
is just a basically a hard particle like
a little sphere but in fact what it
looks more like
is
a wave that looks like that okay so this
has certainly got a
it's got an extent
but you can see that instead of being
just one being at one position which we
could define here
if we put x on this axis again so this
is the position instead of just finding
the particle at one position on the
x-axis we see that it spreads out it's
got this wave-like wave-like character
for me and i think from many um
scientists nanoscientists this is one of
the key
iconic images not just of of nanoscience
in the 20th century but of science in
general it's it's it has really had a
huge impact and um
it's incredibly visceral it really is
visceral this particular image
what we have here um the work was
carried out by a group in ibm and martin
in um in the us
and what they've done is they've
positioned 50 atoms
50 ion atoms on a copper surface so this
is an underlying copper surface and if
they've used something we'll talk about
later i guess a scanning tunneling
microscope which is a sharp basically a
sharp tip you bring it in close to a
surface you move it around and you can
almost literally push these atoms around
and so they form this ring of 50 atoms
that in itself is a wonderful feat of
atomic scale engineering but that's not
what makes this image so beautiful what
makes this image so beautiful is that
it's like you took a stone and you
dropped it in the center here and you
can see these ripples of of what are
electron waves spreading out and what it
is is it's really visual and as i said
visceral um evidence of the wave-like
nature of the electron because the
electrons on this particular surface
spread out like a basically like a sea
of electrons and it's you're dropping
effectively dropping a stone into that
sea of electrons and what's remarkable
is that you can use undergraduate first
and second well second year
undergraduate quantum mechanics to
actually work out the separations of
these rings the spacings of these rings